former White House chef Sam Kass is on a
mission to help Americans eat better
Cass served as a personal chef to the
Obama family and senior advisor for
nutrition policy of the administration
while in the White House Cass LED first
lady Michelle Obama's let's move
campaign and work to set new healthier
standards for school lunches Sam Kass
also helped persuade Walmart to lower
the price of its fruits and vegetables
and cut sugar and sodium content from
its packaged foods his new cookbook is
called eat a little better great flavor
good health better world Cass writes
about small changes that can help
improve our health and the planet Sam
Kass joins us at the table thank you so
much we're so glad you're here and also
we should note you're married to Alex
Wagner it's such a beautiful cookbook
and I'm glad you're sharing so much of
what you learned but you say eat a
little better what do you mean by that
well I think so much we're told is that
there's this perfect diet there's this
right way to eat it's it's very
aspirational and the reality is most
people don't actually eat that way even
the people who are espousing these
perfect diets they're utopic we need to
focus on just making progress and little
steps that people can put into their
daily lives that can actually have a big
impact on their family's health and on
the environment and if you get too big
and all you know go for the stars most
people fail and then get really
demoralized as someone who fails
repeatedly on this front it helped me
what little step can I take I'm in the
I'm in the market what step should I
take I think the first thing that people
can do is try to set themselves up for
success right now we buy a bunch of food
we put it around us in our homes and
then we end up making bad choices you
eat what you see and so you want to put
things on your counter in your fridge
that you're actually trying to eat and
put the treats on the top shelf so when
you want one you still have it but it's
when you really want it as opposed to oh
I saw that cookie I'm gonna eat that
cookie and that's what you helped with
the Obamas when when you first met
Michelle Obama you helped clean out
their pantry yep and it makes a huge
difference because now the kids are
running through the you know the kitchen
and instead of grabbing you know bag of
chips they're grabbing some grapes
because they're just getting what's
around them and I can attest John is in
the market too because he talks about it
every morning that's right
you've made this movie a New York dude
you make house call you talk about kids
and the influence we mentioned that you
had in school systems in the country
about making food healthier we've seen
the Trump administration turned that
around really and say that it's either
too costly and that a lot of these
healthier foods are actually being
thrown away if you could do anything now
to change maybe the initial plan you had
what would that be well I think it's
first important to note that the vast
majority of what we did around nutrition
and health and schools is still intact
there's a little tweaking around the
edges but the majority of what we
accomplished this is there because the
fact of the matter is moms and families
and parents they want good food for
their kids in schools I think the
program needs more money one of the
things you know first and foremost one
of the things that's most inserting
right now is proposals from the GOP to
roll back snap school nutrition
assistance program kicking millions of
vulnerable Americans off of off of food
stamps so like that's that's very
concerning but we need to invest in our
kids well-being it's the foundation of a
thriving economy it's the foundation of
a thriving health care system and if we
don't we're gonna see costs continue to
skyrocket in the decades to come and
you're a new father how has that helped
change how you look at food and feed
your kid and you know you want them to
eat healthy but at times you just want
them to eat sometimes like you just got
to eat something it's been one of it's
been maybe the great joy of my life you
know it really brings it close to home
you see what you're feeding your kid
shapes what they're what they're gonna
like for their whole lives and if
they're getting really sweet foods from
the outset that's what's they're gonna
want from h23 7 and and beyond so
getting kids off of the right start is
like the most important thing we can do
as a society is there a way mine are a
little bit older now than they were but
is there a food that you can sneak by
them that's good for them but that they
might actually tolerate because I
remember the days of fries and white
bread and look I think what we found we
found in the White House and with the
first lady
when we got kids involved so either
planting the garden or deciding you know
what they're gonna buy or participating
in the cooking process that really
opened their minds up to trying new
things because they took ownership of
whatever it was that they were eating
and that I think is that the best
strategy kids like all kinds of foods if
you make it taste even half way good but
if it doesn't taste good they're not
gonna eat it you know that's sort of a
foundation yeah I made a tomato sauce
last night and I sneaked in the carrots
and the red pepper and my son who
doesn't like vegetables loves it it eats
it all up and the first I like that the
first chapter you had in here is grill
and eat more vegetables that's the first
place you started because I think people
are scared about how to cook vegetables
yeah and like there's nothing that makes
something taste better than a grill yeah
and it couldn't be easier put a little
olive oil on it some salt and pepper
maybe a little lemon and anything you
could put on there tastes good and I
think we focus so much on the what we're
supposed to do but what I try to do a
lot in this book is focused on the how
the vast majority of Americans are
trying to eat better but they're failing
and they're feeling because we don't
actually give strategies and to
implement these changes in our daily
lives and so everybody ends up falling
short and then just sort of throwing
their hands up and giving up but if we
make these kind of steps not only can we
transform our own health but have a huge
impact on the environment I mean food
and agriculture is the number two driver
of climate change of greenhouse gas
emissions it's the number one cause of
preventable death and disease so we can
solve some of these fundamental problems
into what we're eating every day have a
huge impact on so many the challenges
that we're facing not many people have
an impact on the president and the first
family the way you have you write in the
book that the Secret Service got used to
you running through the White House
because you had to have dinner on the
table by 6:30 yeah what was it like I
mean now looking back you've had a few
years to reflect on working with the
first family and feeding them literally
yeah well it was first the greatest
honor of my life and I think we'll
always be it was intense and you know
because of all the policy work and let's
move working for the first lady
you know dinner was like I felt often
like a sort of a single parent like oh
my god I gotta get to dinner on the
table got 30 minutes but the thing that
struck me most was that no matter where
he was or where she was they
dinner's a family unless he was overseas
or in California they ate as a family
every night and he left everything that
he was dealing with at the door okay
same casts we're gonna have to go eat a
little better goes on sale tomorrow